[Música]
a la
realidad
hadi human es un antiguo boy scout que
vive en el noreste de yemen donde desde
2016 trabaja como mediador voluntario en
el conflicto entre los combatientes
útiles y las fuerzas progubernamentales
una de sus principales misiones es
recoger los cadáveres de los que han
muerto en combate y llevárselos a sus
familias aquí lo vemos recoger cuerpos
en la zona de yubá en el noreste del
país en donde perdieron la vida al menos
14 combatientes útiles y 10 soldados
progubernamentales en 5 años -ha dicho-
man y su equipo de voluntarios han
conseguido devolver más de 1000 cuerpos
de combatientes a sus familias una mala
no gozaría con mi equipo trabajamos en
las regiones del noreste en unas 7
provincias y en la frontera entre yemen
y arabia saudita con los jóvenes
voluntarios que trabajan conmigo hemos
vivido muchas situaciones peligrosas
hemos sido objeto de ataques al menos a
veces
el avión acaba de ser bombardeado a
pocos metros el equipo de hadi human
trabaja con pocos medios económicos
recientemente presentaron una campaña de
recaudación de fondos en las redes
sociales aunque los beligerantes suelen
aceptar su ayuda no le proporcionan
medios financieros ni logísticos
particularmente necesitamos dos
vehículos un vehículo para el equipo y
otro para transportar los cuerpos nos
faltan trajes de protección y también
necesitamos bolsas para cadáveres tengo
muchos acuerdos pendientes porque no
tengo bolsas para cadáveres disponibles
los equipos de mediación de hadi human
también intentan facilitar las
negociaciones para el intercambio de
prisioneros está implicado directamente
con las dos partes del conflicto y no
está exento de los riesgos
corremos otros peligros porque a menudo
somos objeto de sospecha a veces un
bando nos acusa de estar en el bando
contrario yo mismo he estado encarcelado
8 veces
pero sean cuales sean los obstáculos
nadie nos impedirá seguir trabajando es
una labor humanitaria una obra que
satisface a dios y también a los
familiares de los detenidos y mártires
[Aplausos]
yo soy
en el departamento francés de mayo en el
océano índico los enfrentamientos entre
las bandas juveniles rivales han
aumentado desde el inicio del curso
escolar el pasado mes de septiembre este
es el caso en particular el de las
inmediaciones de la escuela secundaria
cani una institución con casi 2.000
estudiantes ante esta violencia los
profesores de este centro hacen sonar
las alarmas como jeremy ces o profesor
de literatura y también representante
sindical
por lo general las bandas de jóvenes se
pelean delante del establecimiento y en
el establecimiento bandas de diferentes
pueblos
lanzan piedras pero también varillas
metálicas de 80 centímetros de longitud
que son especialmente peligrosas a la
entrada de la escuela y también a los
alumnos
desde septiembre hemos sufrido unos
siete enfrentamientos también hay armas
blancas que entran en la escuela la
policía móvil está presente casi a
tiempo completo frente a la escuela y
cuando interviene utiliza gases
lacrimógenos y granadas explosivas
así que escuchamos todos esos ruidos
durante esos actos a veces cuando
estamos en el aula
lo que me preocupa especialmente es la
dificultad actual de razonar con los
alumnos
[Aplausos]
los profesores se han manifestado varias
veces frente a estas escuelas
secundarias de cahan y para exigir más
seguridad la crisis social que vive la
isla desde hace varios años podría ser
una de las razones del aumento de la
violencia
estamos llegando a más del 70% de las
personas que están por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza con alimentos
extremadamente caros la gente de aquí no
puede sobrevivir viven en barriadas
donde no hay agua ni electricidad y las
casas son de latas ni siquiera hablo de
las condiciones de nuestros alumnos en
la época de lluvias que obviamente no
pueden trabajar en casa en 2018 la
violencia en varios centros educativos
ya había provocado una huelga general de
tres meses contra la inseguridad la
circunscripción de mayor está
invirtiendo en la construcción de nuevas
escuelas y en la contratación de
personal el objetivo es garantizar un
mejor acceso a la educación en este
territorio donde más de la mitad de la
población es menor de 20 años
esto es en el aeropuerto de minsk donde
la situación es muy muy mal
belarús empezó a expulsar a los
inmigrantes que había atraído desde el
verano boreal con la promesa de
permitirles un fácil acceso a la unión
europea en realidad la mayoría de ellos
estaban bloqueados en la frontera con
polonia algunos optaron por regresar a
su país pero desde el pasado 5 de
diciembre otros fueron llevados por la
fuerza a un aeropuerto cercano esto
provocó tensiones que nuestro observador
presenció
anteayer vinieron ofrecían dos opciones
o atravesar la frontera o volver a
nuestros países si volvemos a nuestros
países es peor que la selva porque cada
uno con su propia historia no es fácil
[Aplausos]
con las fuertes condiciones climáticas
muchos migrantes se niegan a volver a la
frontera y han realizado manifestaciones
para pedir ayuda a nivel internacional
nieva la temperatura es muy baja para
los niños las familias salieron a la
calle sobre todo los niños tienen ayuda
al papa en el vaticano
pedimos a la unión europea que nos ayude
y que tome una buena decisión de una vez
por todas para salir de esta situación
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si quieren
comunicarse con la producción del
programa para enviarnos sus historias
fotografías y videos los datos de
contacto aparecen en sus pantallas
esperamos sus mensajes gracias por
acompañarnos nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad hasta entonces